[Music]
welcome everybody to another episode of
the h3 podcast la that's right we are
back and we are streaming on YouTube we
come over you can give a shot and see
what it feels like because we've never
actually watched from the showing you
know the congressman lives here so I
thought it would be a fun experience to
see how the experience differs just to
mix it up a little bit keep you on your
toes
today's episode is sponsored by hims
blue apron and expressvpn ela you are
looking by the way working down are we
live we're live but I think you're
watching this on Twitch you can do a
pre-show el escape that I never want to
go back that was the sound of hell was
it okay if you go through hell that's
why you heard you much that is eternal
death well it's really different between
the two because on twitchy of 30 minutes
to just [ __ ] around why you a stream
because we take it off we cut it and put
it on YouTube here you live stream in
the bud just wherever it lives there
shall we be buried there's no take-backs
here so it's a little more stressful I'm
a little more on edge you know
there's no take-backs there's no
starting over like if I slip a couple
racial slurs on twitch it can be like
hey let's maybe cut the slurs Ethan not
that that happens this happens so many
times people don't know if as we cut it
actually a huge I'm hugely racist but we
have good editors oh there's so much to
get to today I'm actually really
supported a show we have a ton of new
stuff we're trying
including our first ever live
performance musical we have completely
pimped out the back room we have chaos
chaos which is really wonderful I would
say indie rock I feel like that's a good
yeah descript there uncredible I can't
wait for you guys to hear them they're
gonna be playing at the bottom of the
show we are going to talk about my
social media detox talking about logan
paul getting a bisecting me from chris
d'elia on twitter he straight-up snipped
his tubes and i know you guys don't like
me talking about logan paul because i do
talk about him a lot but give me a
[ __ ] break it's the he's humiliated
himself so hard how am I not supposed to
talk he gave him a prostate exam any
snipped his tubes all in one move I dare
you to find an ass doctor that can do
that [ __ ] finger in and I'm telling
you Chris D'Elia is an incredible
surgeon what else that's about it let's
get right now flip into it so you guys
probably know that I was we we were
taking a week break we where we weren't
using social media for a full week seven
days pretty much well it was a big a
stave a keishon and I had just got this
feeling that I was wasting so much
[ __ ] time on all these social medias
it was the first thing I would do you
know in the morning you it when you
catch yourself it's so bad when you
catch yourself going for that phone like
your eyes open and like even before your
first thought or impulse to pee enters
your head the phone is the first impulse
that's sick yeah the first thing I'll do
Instagram right and I'm not even active
I barely post on rice to go yeah but
I'll scroll down every morning for like
an hour everybody listening probably
knows about this impulse that we all
have for me it's Facebook I never use it
but I've been using that website for so
frickin long it was my first social
media that alt when I open a browser I
will inflexibly without thinking start
typing Facebook and it's so [ __ ] up
and these days I'll still do it just
from like must remember but I'll close
it immediately because I don't want that
[ __ ]
so iced and not only the time-wasting
but also I feel like it was making me
unhappy because you're always thinking
about all these other people you're
worrying about all these other people
what they're doing yeah you know
everyone else is having so much fun
right and they look so good making
amazing good [ __ ] yeah it's like
everything else looks so good and then
you sort of feel this sadness yeah and
and you're not living in the physical
world your head is in you're just
consumed by all this [ __ ] but you
don't even think about what's in front
of you people are in front of you every
you know the physical world and I have
this feeling to that spending so much
time on social media actually impairs my
thoughts I feel like I don't think as
clearly or as freely because it
literally just is it is a distraction
you and your own social media you're not
thinking about [ __ ] so it's almost like
you know in brave new world they give
you these caps so you can't think yeah
it's kind of what Twitter is in a weird
way you know I don't know because I used
to love Instagram but now Instagram is
just as depressing as all your wife
Facebook about it right ruin everything
so let me tell you about how my week was
um so all throughout the week first of
all I was I had to erase YouTube and
Twitter and Instagram off my phone first
of all because you just catch yourself
aimlessly clicking open the tab mm-hmm
and you look at it for a second before
you realize like oh [ __ ] I'm not
supposed to be doing this but that's too
much yeah so it was really a beautiful
thing when I erased it off my phone I
would go to look for it out of memory
and then I'd be like that's right it's
not there so I feel like that step was
super important first of all but the
thing first of all that I realized was
like how much free time you have like
I'll wake up in the morning and I'll
I'll wake up at 8:00 a.m. and all
without thinking about it literally
waste two [ __ ] hours on my phone
on reddit reddit is a bad one I didn't
visit reddit at all either reddit or
Twitter of all these guys yeah yeah you
so I'll wake up at 8 a.m. and I grab my
phone I'm like I'll go to like a news
site and see the headlines and like well
I can't [ __ ] around on a news page for
two hours so then I'm just stuck with
myself so I ended up doing all this [ __ ]
like I fixed some exercise machine think
about [ __ ] put on put on TV watch a show
which is something so crazy I like I
might I don't have time to watch my
favorite show
I'm so [ __ ] busy meanwhile you're
late you're wasting two hours every
morning so I put on a show you know or
I'll put on a video game by the way beat
got award yeah fantastic was the last
time I beat a video game yeah fantastic
ela hated that Sun it's like I'm alone
in the house there's no one to talk to
Ethan cannot get up he cannot help you
can't walk shredder he's paralyzed it's
like being alone but ucation let me play
my game woman I hate it okay well that's
that's a conversation for another time
I loved that game so much I recommend
everyone play God work it was a ton of
fun the storytelling was breathtaking
and if you have a significant other
they'll love it
well they'll love that they love it I
guess the fact that almost means that
you love me that we have a good
relationship right yeah because if you
hated me
you'd be like play your game no I hate
being like alone and then I'm like so
lonely the [ __ ] was I saying so god I
lost my train of thought from the God of
War what were you talking about the time
and you watch the show right so I would
turn on a television show and I would
really enjoy watching a documentary or a
movie or a show that I like and
you know classically when we were kids
TV was thought to be the biggest time
waster of all time and I'm thinking
they're thinking like this is not a bad
activity because to consume telev to
consume media in that way you have to be
at home you have to be in a physical
location you have to have the time set
aside to sit there if it's 2 or 3 hours
or whatever you have to be there and you
have to have that time allotted for it
yeah and you're taking in a creative
work of something or somebody there's
some value there right somebody poured a
lot of soul and energy into creating
that now if you compare that to social
media okay
social media has taken time wasting
procrastination to levels never before
seen because you have in your pocket the
ability to waste time anywhere any
[ __ ] where you are you can blow an
hour no problem and here's the part that
really gets you it there's nothing of
value there nothing a television show is
a beautiful work of art the blood sweat
tears and creative vision of hundreds of
people
social media is nothing are you telling
me that Logan Paul is not putting out
creative all right on Twitter tweeting
well there's some debate there's some
division be out there I'm being
hyperbolic of course you must carve out
a space for Logan Paul with everything
you talk about but like there is nothing
of value lost if you're off Twitter for
a week you lose nothing it's just you
know what I mean that's that's ten hours
of your life in the physical plane of
existence so the first two days were
hard I was kind of anxious and the thing
is you feel out of the loop you know
mm-hmm the really hard one for me was
not going on reddit but that one was
really important to to not to and you
feel you're missing out on stuff like
apparently Kanye and Justin roiland
we're tweeting at each other and we're
gone
dates we got updates in a group chat
about that one but like don't yeah the
worst was ready cuz I get my news from
there but I just went on like a news
website and got it there and you death
taking five minutes yeah you you really
you feel like you're missing so much but
you're not if there's a big headline you
hear about it on the radio you hear
about it everybody from friends yeah
like people used to Nome and is a Island
you're not you're not disconnected if
you're not a reddit there's people that
don't use reddit believe it or not I
actually don't really you know from that
what I'll check the subreddit sometimes
but are you [ __ ] crazy
I love reddit so much it's a problem but
it turns into all the other social
medias I'll go to reddit and I start
scrolling and what happens is you're
getting a dopamine kick like when you do
a drug a reward system that like that on
all social media and it's harder and
harder to get that satisfaction of like
oh I love this post that's just what I
was looking for and I'll go to Reddit
and I'll scroll for pages and pages
until I find something I'm like that was
you know what I mean I skimmed that
[ __ ] so hard now anyway
I'm now that I'm back I kind of
begrudgingly reinstalled all the apps on
my phone I didn't want to because I felt
just like mm-hmm so blissful but it's
kind of weird for us cuz it's also kind
of work yeah
to to tweet and post and stuff like that
like I have to fresh and yeah just to be
present oh yeah it is important I think
what I'm gonna try doing as much as
possible is just doing a post and then
getting out mm-hmm
I mean no you know everyone's I just
gotta get out and no offense to anyone
who's making bomb ass tweets out there I
just need to get out I don't think it's
healthy what we're doing to ourselves
and then this brought me to another
question that I had for myself I'm
thinking we used to goof on this guy
Prince yeah who made this video like
look up from your phone as super
dramatic and corny and I used to be like
you know this guy he's talking [ __ ] on
phones like shut up just don't you
your phone and I used to blast this guy
say he's such a nerd and I was like wait
am I like what's the difference between
me now because my morale I'm saying that
I don't think so show me is good for me
it really took it's like right it took
us like a couple of days we were like
wait well we were making fun of him and
now we're like them I need to reassess
that because I still feel like the
correlation is not exact yeah I don't
know if I'm in denial
you know what I mean well let's watch
the video because let me refresh some
you guys's memory this is what we're
talking about here let me pull this up
where the flippin heck here it is down
at his self did you know the average
person spends four years of his life
looking down at a cellphone you get that
I don't know alright the bad like
alright alright I'm just gonna let it
play i'ma let you guys watch this it's
hard for me not like I agree with them I
think now but let's watch the vid but
it's the way they like their music did
you know that average person spends four
years this video came out like four
years ago I mean people were only using
social media heavily for like four years
it wasn't as bad as it is today when he
made the video so what's the office yeah
where's your head of his time right I
will never give him credit but let's be
honest about it that's why I brown okay
nice touch screens can make us like this
is the [ __ ] see what he's doing is like
well what he's doing is like when so I
don't believe that I think what I'm
talking about is like somebody on a
toilet taking a [ __ ] vibe on Twitter
when we go to dinner or anyone today
goes to dinner do you not open your
phone but is that a problem between
relationships like she's there like
seriously dude I just want to live my
life I guess that's that's a problem
that he taught like the problems with
the relationship the problem is with
everybody everybody's doing it you don't
have a problem no everybody's doing it
right it's the from you and yourself he
was speaking the problem with his video
I'm not
let it play for you guys yeah but let me
just say this I think the problem with
this video is that he's speaking to this
like these enlightened few who are like
I see the problem I have a flip phone I
only use Nokia's from 1993 I'm
enlightened like unlike all my plebeian
scumbag friends
he was an iPhone [ __ ] peasant
[ __ ] I'm on a higher plane of
existence it's funny cuz we used to kind
of be like that for a while like we
didn't have a smartphone when everyone
else did
remember for for the longest time our
plane of existence all the car videos
were better but eventually you got to
get that smartphone I think it's the
coming from that place of like authority
of like we know we are enlightened and
we see the problem with the world they
don't they are the problem it's like
it's like the vegans who give vegans bad
rap because they're like right preachy
about it yeah you need to look up like
we were at we were actually at a
restaurant this week which rather
outside sitting and a lady came to me
and she was like you're eating here and
I'm like yeah and she was like you know
you shouldn't like there's no difference
between what you're eating and and like
she pointed at shredder yeah and it's
like you know you make maybe you're
making a good point but like why I don't
know leave me alone the reluctant to be
like that's fine point but at the same
time do you do this to everybody you see
with the dog who's eating and I am
approached a conversation with you and
like I'm trying to having lunch right
now which I'm trying to live my life you
[ __ ] move on please but the thing
that you don't erst and is that she's on
a higher plane of enlightenment okay
like you can't possibly understand the
vast intellect that her and this guy
they looking down from like Mount
Olympus and you can't possibly
understand did you know that that people
waste four years of their life on their
phones you know by the time someone
seven years old they've wasted six years
of their life on their phone do the math
no not four hours you said four years Oh
me wait let's well four hours isn't that
drastic definitely
yeah that's what I have for years did
you know did you know that when somebody
turns five they've already wasted four
years of their life on their phony law
that's pretty rough it will shock you
but if only they could ascend to God
like enlightenment they wouldn't
understand if only they could flip their
collar like me Prince idea
it's the colour-pop you can't get on
here on your soapbox and expect me to
not to take you seriously with the
collar pop like that and why do you got
to go stand on the pier you know beyond
that it's like that you is wearing all
white on the beach it's like I'm a saint
yeah I'm Jesus Christ there's a problem
there the real setting should be a dude
on the [ __ ] or dude who just woke up
a bed that's where people waste the time
right like give me a [ __ ] break while
you at the pier
all right let's watch this [ __ ] Oh
Ronnie Gainey why are you doing this
like what are you doing what do you what
do you he's just he's just so stoked
with all the beautiful thoughts he's
having right now
kind of ironic in it like just it's just
I don't know can we autocorrect humanity
by the way all right I just need to let
this play I'm getting too riled up nice
little play all right here we go Prince
I had these touch screens can make us
lose touch setting but it's no wonder in
a world filled with IMAX iPad and iPhone
so many I so many selfies not enough us
isn't we see technology has made us more
selfish and separate than ever because
while it claims to connect this
connection has gotten no better I don't
know that that's the re right he's
talking about like oh we're disconnected
social media but I actually disagree
with that I think people are more
connected that's true I don't know if
it's a healthy kind of connection you
know what I mean I don't know that you
need your mom you shouldn't be that
closely connected we're too connected I
think he's wrong all right i'ma shut up
just watch
not to be rude you should mr. Zuckerberg
not to be rude but I think you should
really kill yourself when that be a
great twist mr. Zuckerberg I don't want
to be rude but your address is 1 1 4 3
Silver Lake and I am on the way with a
weapon Oh too much that's just a joke
he's not really but yeah too much tone
it down
god I wish I could edit that one out
antisocial Network I think he's wrong
about that I think I don't know he's
more he's more he's missing on the wrong
parts he's more interested in sounding
smart and looking like anyone know this
you know what I mean okay I think we've
seen enough but maybe on friendships are
more broken in the squeeze on off every
phones we sit home or not not to be rude
mr. Zuckerberg but I do have somebody
trailing you and your family we've taken
pictures of you and your window every
night and I don't mean to be rude mr.
Zuckerberg but I am a dangerous man and
I did pass a background check recently
I've just interesting if that was the
poem just putting a twist on it knowing
those that like us they'd rather write
post and talk to someone who might
actually hope might actually hug us and
make you tell me cuz you tell me cuz mr.
Zuckerberg are you just a Borg and
furthermore my caller be popping by the
way you know that today this guy is on
his phone all day bro this [ __ ] guy
is hustling so hard on social media
taking his views that's right huh um can
we
autocorrect human we autocorrect your
YouTube channel
there's that irony but yeah there is
that irony of trying to take down so she
may think it's like you said the problem
is that he's doing it from like the
perspective like I'm better yeah I see
the problem so it's you yeah okay we've
seen enough I love this video though
should I keep watch I'm gonna keep
watching I don't give a [ __ ] I love this
video this video is a classic I said
alright alright what time do you wanna
Skype I guarantee that summer things you
never have that is the dumbest what time
you want to Skype let's meet up face to
face what time you want to Skype come on
I got a front like that happened look at
the anguish she's in right now my friend
wanted to Skype he was the friend what
about me
do I not have the patience to have a
conversation without abbreviation this
is the generation of media over
stimulation chats have been reduced to
snaps the news is 140 characters videos
at 6 seconds and high-speed and you
wonder why a DD is on the rise faster
than 4G LTE but get a load of this fly
though oh yeah your shirt is still
relatable to relatable yeah yeah just I
wish had a fat Grateful Dead caller yeah
that'd be sick I guarantee you a human
has more attention span than a goldfish
if you're able to test that Prince EA I
know kind of labs you're working in did
you know that by the time a child is too
years old they've wasted 20 years of
their life on the ocean they've
literally never looked up from their
phone it's crazy what's going on today
you know it's so like this reminds me of
our tech video we made but it's
literally a parody of this video yes but
this one my friends we cannot
autocorrect we must do it ourselves
take control be contracted make a
decision make a scene no longer do I
want to spoil the precious moment by
recording it with a fire I get it yeah I
got it
Prince a so I don't know I don't think
so i think i don't maybe I am maybe I
maybe he was ahead of the time I don't
know I just can't I can't put it in my
head that me and that guy are on the
same page on this you know I mean that's
their approach it's the approach yeah so
he was right well can we autocorrect
humanity are you saying that no I don't
know that I can say that he was
completely right no no no no I think we
should art we actually have a call
coming in from herb from Las Vegas who
has something to share about social
media Colin yeah let me uh let me patch
it through one sec basically I think
that I'm Otto correcting humanity by not
going on Twitter I think what I'm doing
I'm calling it the autocorrect movement
Oh
and so basically I'm enlightened are you
gonna start a hashtag no oh here what's
up you got a way for us because I was
born when you know Billy addictions I
got it you know I used to smoke my wife
made me quit you know I had all these
things stop it right bit because I was
hurt
but my biggest of all was every night I
would crawl into bed and I would look my
wife at the eyes and she would let me
suck on her teeth but one day it was a I
don't know it is not bad but one day she
got sick with her you say whooping cough
she was whooping whooping whooping they
had to go to the hospital was dying
almost that is tragic
but okay what thank you for calling in
so herb what do you think about Twitter
I've used Twitter do you think it's a
problem with today's society
how about Ian did you screen this I was
thean supposed to screen the calls to
make sure they're on message but I don't
so you tell me more about sucking your
wife's tit and and she was lactating at
the time that sounds like a really awful
a dictionary thank you thank you we can
cut herb off well I'm sorry about that I
was an interesting guy yeah I have a
talk with Ian he said this guy had a
good question huh I apologize huh
that was a how old do you think F was
man he's barely hanging on earth I wish
I liked herb though I feel like he has
he kind of twisted up on side of its
head because we're here we're thinking
about social media and I'm saying let's
live in the physical world mm-hmm and
what herbs is doing by sucking on his
wife's you know what sounded like
infected Ted he said yellow no it's kind
of a wake-up call to all of us that
there's a lot to offer in this physical
realm that we all live in so we have got
a ton more to get to my dudes so much
freakin content okay
we're gonna go to a brief break don't go
we are trying something new we broke it
each commercial break into one read okay
so we're not talking about some
ten-minute block it's a quickie is a
great people I want you to buy this
product get your wallets out I don't
know do whatever you want but just don't
leave okay
we'll be right back love you guys thanks
for watching then we're not leaving
we'll be right back thank you to hims
for sponsoring us 66% of men go fricking
bald by age 35 that's insane that is
unbelievable is that true well if they
wrote it yeah well they lie to me but if
you take a sample of the office like in
and Dan are both are thinning so that's
a 50% so my my study alone in this
office is 50% thinning hair why you
gotta call my I mean it's a matter of
fact I'm not calling him out you just
you look at him you just like your hair
is thinning I don't think that they
would be offended that I would say that
it's a matter of fact it's like oh you
were yeah you're Jewish
oh sorry that I offended you it's just
I'm looking at you and you've got a GE
ass face you don't actually I got you
don't have a Jew ass face I do let's get
to the point hems alright
it's easier to keep the damn here that
you've got than to do all kinds of
shenanigans after it's already gone why
do you guys turn to weird solutions or
do nothing when they can turn to
medicine and science and keep that
beautiful luscious head of hair before
it's too late
for hems calm a one-stop shop for hair
loss and skin care for men thanks to
science baldness can be optional hems
connects you with real doctors to treat
hair loss well they got a well known
generic generic equivalent to name-brand
prescriptions to help you keep your hair
answer a few quick questions doctors
were what the hell doctors will review
and can prescribe you products are
shipped directly to your door Dan our
producer suffers from crippling brutal
baldness and he's got a personal story
to tell he has a personal
anecdote that he'd like to share come in
he's been on hems for about a week now
and things are just one day actually he
started he just this morning and things
have really shaping up for dance in that
time Dan the producer dr. sward Love has
he walked down the street and how many
women were to give you a blow like how
many people just touched your dick
there's two dozen it's two dozen 24
[ __ ] just did you get it did you get
any and GJ's yeah did you get any DJ
stop bragging stop bragging about
another week guys order now my listeners
get a free dang trout for just fun well
it's not a free trial it's five dollars
not free five dollars but it's
practically free to look like this right
now while supplies last
see website for full details this would
cost hundreds if you went to a doctor or
pharmacy so go to for hims calm /h 3 fo
r hims dot-com slash age 3 4 episode
Cobb slash age 3 keep that beautiful
head of hair get your dick sucked by
some [ __ ] cuties that love here is
that I don't know that helped you hope
that helped you will get back right into
it welcome back my little dumplings can
that beer clan rank of the clan the
clown sounds bad it sounds like
including the klu klux klan ruined the
clan in my opinion like hitler ruined
the name hitler and the mustache mm-hmm
you can't be like hey were the clan it's
like what do you do what do you guys do
what does your clan do if not it races
[ __ ] um next Friday he'll is gone she's
going on a last-minute trip to Israel to
visit the family yeah yeah my dad is
still fighting the lung cancer mm-hm and
so just trying to make it out there as
much as I can you know it's hard good
it's such a long flight little a 20-hour
trouble yeah that's the worst but
so I do plan on getting like super trash
that both stood when she's gone and just
starting [ __ ] with anyone that will
listen pretty much yeah that's what
happened last time just to you know take
the stress off her and make sure that
was great last time I think well fine I
think I'll try to find a co-host so I'm
gonna sit in we'll do something we'll
figure something out but so either will
not be here next Friday but the world
will go on and maybe I can get Prince EA
in there you know what I mean
he becomes a interesting Colin our guest
no I'm sure call wouldn't be great
Prince EA Colin if you're out there I
want to get him on the show I would
totally have his s on the show I want to
know how much how many years of his life
he's wasted on social yeah if he's been
keeping count here's a little story I
had to bring up you guys probably saw
the video we made about the cultural
appropriation of the Chinese dress that
the girl were from and it's been it's
been a while because we were off the
internet but some lunatic one on the
news and was well just listen to this
for yourself that were I think she
thought were Asian poses but they were
actually vapenation and promoting some
youtuber that is controversial in itself
what she's so like she's like okay maybe
it's not making fun of Asian people okay
but the channel that they are and still
not okay yeah what is hugely problematic
you don't know me you crazy Idol lunatic
like that's the best argument you've got
in defense of cultural appropriation
operating but but I like how she says I
think is controversial on an assumption
watch you're not sure but you're gonna
say that it's controversy like I went to
the channel and it seemed fine but like
I don't have a lot of time I'm sure
they've said something problem so let's
just go with that you know he's a racist
he's a bigot
he hates black people and he's wasted at
least thirty years of his life on social
media though what do you get do you guys
remember we clowned on this woman before
on the podcast maybe no maybe it's
personal vendetta she on the same show
with Tucker she was the woman who
thought breastfeeding was sexist yeah
maybe she's got a you know what there
you know Fox News does because they like
such partisan hacks like seeing as apart
they're all partisan hacks they get like
the dumbest person ever to represent
animals right cartoons okay well here's
Carol our kooky liberal correspondent I
think that everything's racist I'm
[ __ ] crazy and I own five cats I mean
ten cats I don't use my phone at all she
looks nuts get a load of that man I'd
like to see her in a Chinese dress not
in a sexual way I don't mean it like
that I just like that she's she's saying
that she has no idea what they're doing
in the picture right but it's still
problematic I admit that the grey hands
they're doing isn't cultural
appropriation and they are not making
fun of Asian culture however it's still
offensive because they're doing a Papa
blessed and as we all know a straight
story is kind of problematic and I've
already written all their sponsors I've
already written to YouTube there we're
gonna get them shut down this is
entirely inappropriate and I heard that
Ethan once had an improper thought he
once had an improper thought and I could
just tell by looking at him I can
obviously tell what he was thinking but
I've reported to the thought police
aka YouTube I don't know whatever I
thought that was cute promoting some
youtuber that is controversial in itself
and she's praying what are you even
talking about
[Laughter]
appreciating a culture that's opposed
mocking
a culture nice [ __ ] try dum-dum huh
how do you get from there what do
according to her anytime you're wearing
a Chinese dress you need to be somehow
appreciating how do you appreciate that
how do you know if the person is
appreciating you're reading their mind
like how are you gonna know what it that
is such a weird argument well she's just
like the biggest loan ever because Fox
News they did like casting calls they
they interviewed like thousands of
people to find this perfect liberal kook
you know didn't mean damn that's some
nutty [ __ ] no wonder FoxNews listeners
hate liberals they see people like this
all day I would hate him too if this is
this should I wash that was the most Oh
coherent thought maybe statement I've
ever heard look at her face even she
knows that was not my name either she
wouldn't dare drop my name I don't want
to give him the satisfaction of me even
saying he's controversial I love that
there's a Papa John culture I wouldn't
even say his name she if she would want
it to be respecting Chinese culture she
would have been giving praise to Panda
Express this is so inappropriate we need
to this is the pot the Panda Express
they would have been appreciating Panda
Express if they were gonna appreciate
Chinese culture I don't know what she
wants but I love her and I wish her the
best
God buzz you know what I saw Lily sings
on Jimmy Kimmel last night yeah mm-hmm
you guys probably know her big big big
youtuber she does impressions of her
parents other stuff and I just love how
whenever a youtuber new media
personality goes on like a traditional
media platform they're always so
condescending and I don't even think
that Jimmy's like conscious of it
but it's always like hey fella hey
little guy how'd you get here or they
always have to make like they have to go
the extra step of being like I invited
you here because my daughter's a huge
fan I just wanted to remind you that I
didn't invite you here on your merit
alone yeah and I don't want any of my
viewers to think that I actually watch
your stuff here's a couple clips of
Jimmy talking to Lily sings how the hell
do you even answer that question it's so
stupid
had you become so popular on YouTube
tell me about what you do is it a hobby
how do you make money do you make money
on YouTube how'd you become so popular
aren't you great
can you imagine asking Jimmy how did you
get how'd you get here
mm-hmm so you're the late-night show
host how'd that happen that's so great
how'd you get so popular on YouTube and
I don't know that's a big question it
was kind of a shame because I'm a Jimmy
Kimmel fan but I got it he's part of the
establishment the question was pretty
lame you're such a cutie pie you're such
a sweetheart how'd you get popular
what'd you do you do like uh you make
like like jokes or you like vlog or what
do you like make vlogs that's so cool
you get in view you get money you get
paid for just posting videos Wow Wow
that is incredible how did you how did
you afford this uh how did you afford
this first lady orange jumpsuit that
looks expensive they pay you on YouTube
here's another clip I hate that
it's so good meaning like just imagine
somebody being like how'd you get here
Jimmy or like any [ __ ] she's also
promoting a movie but imagine anyone
else is like a like a beginning actress
on the first time when a movie imagine
him asking how cute you get that would
be so rude did you get that job it's
unbelievable oh yeah
the other one it's funny they were
promoting a movie and he didn't even
mention the movie or show the clip it
was a strangest promotional segment of
all time okay so now you're in this HBO
movie which is very very exciting oh boy
it's really rare I think that somebody
will make the leap from YouTube to like
HBO which is about as good as it gets
right it's pretty cool I mean how'd you
how'd you do that so you made it from
YouTube to HBO that never happens HBO is
about as good as it gets much better
than from how'd that happen
tell me about that process aren't you uh
aren't you a lucky girl asking a
professional athlete Kobe had so how did
you get on the NBA lots of hard work
lots of debt I don't know how anyone
succeeds Jimmy it's funny Jimmy's calm
perfectly cut not just Jimmy but all
these guys are perfectly comfortable
stealing everyone's content on YouTube
for a little [ __ ] filler vids you
know what I mean and not giving them any
credit yeah I see that [ __ ] all the time
it drives me crazy how'd you get here
so you just make videos and they they
pay you get paid
how's that work you just sit at home you
work from home are you in your underwear
well you probably don't even get dressed
tell me about yourself my daughter loves
you I invited you because my daughter
loves you that should just drive me
crazy I've seen that a lot yeah almost
literally every time like when Logan
Paul was on Jimmy Kimmel he specifically
went out of his way to say I invited you
I made the effort to invite you not like
they never say that if a superstar comes
up you know what I mean yeah I went out
of my way to send you an offer from the
graciousness because I know you got to
give love to get love giving you this
huge break even though you're on YouTube
is a big way to go how'd you get here by
the way you just make videos from your
home to use a webcam you have a real
camera that's crazy
do you buy your own equipment they're
using did your mom give you a did you
buzz it started with Ag like a Christmas
gift little handheld you use your phone
you have a real camera that's terrific
good for you that's wonderful
that's super I got a beef with in our
intern he has caused me so much [ __ ]
grief yeah yes get in on the microphone
I need him involved in this yes sir yes
sir one moment sir I think you've got
that you're gonna kind of filter on that
by the way down though
how could that happen I don't know what
you mean here we got him here what do
you want are you there listen closely
him I got a bone to pick you son of a
gun
so Ian heartbreak are you there Ian can
you hear me yes so his car broke he just
got a new car and it broke down after a
couple weeks it was tragic
so we gave him one of our Prius which we
don't drive that much and we said borrow
this for the next week and God bless and
what he did we were he got us a gift
card for like 40 bucks to Sharkey's
Mexican Grill as a thing and I'll tell
you what in this card has been nothing
but a [ __ ] curse on my life and I and
I am so pissed at you I've tried to use
this card so many but I've wasted so
much money trying to use this card
Sharkey I don't want to eat shark I
don't like their food I don't like
anything about Sharky's right now I've
gone there I've gone there three times
I've ordered online okay and the card
never works and you end up paying for it
yourself doesn't happen three [ __ ]
time you can't use it online and I'm
already to the point of no return where
it's like I'm not gonna go like do you
do you know how hard it is to make lunch
plans in you don't understand how hard
it is like yeah I can't go when I'm
already at checkout and be like I'm
gonna go start over somewhere else
that's [ __ ] do you know how hard it is
to make lunch plans Ian
I mean I can imagine okay well you don't
make lunch blinds I mean I've picked up
lunch okay for other people
Ian's never made a lunch plan in his
life trust me it's hard okay now I says
to myself a couple days ago three days
ago we you know what what are we gonna
eat for lunch
let's go to Sharky's I've got this
[ __ ] gift card I'm sick of having it
and we were also in a tight window
because we had a little make it
somewhere else afterwards so we're like
quick we're busy right we have tight
schedules and we don't have a lot of
time for lunch plans Ian so we roll up
to Sharky's Neil is outside with the dog
I go I order our food whatever you know
and I'll tell you what cuz there's 40
bucks on the card I ordered a little
extra [ __ ] that I would never move let's
just bang it out I got like a side of
co-op and a Greek and all this [ __ ]
and added stuff cuz you're like let's
just bang it out even though I wouldn't
pay to ever pay for that it's on Ian
these mother [ __ ] they go to me after
I place my order
the system's down well we're gonna try
to fix it so I placed my order they make
the food after like two minutes because
it's not that busy they put it on the
counter it's right there are you
listening in okay it's sitting there on
the counter
I go to fill up the sauces and they're
punching away people are coming and
getting their food I walk up and say hey
what's going on we're still working out
the kinks we're trying to figure this
out ten minutes later the manager comes
out calls up like corporate headquarters
just trying to hit this gift card to
work they go do you know how much money
is on this card I'm like I don't know
I'm not you know the hell do I know like
okay just just sir relax
oh screaming I was throwing sauce at the
wall
so after like 20 minutes the food is
[ __ ] cold I go up I says alright
listen I I have to go I'm a busy man I
don't have lunch plant time and they say
can you use it another day can you pay
with your car yeah I was like you gotta
be [ __ ] kidding me do you know how
hard I've been trying to use this money
so now I've spent like a hundred and
fifty [ __ ] dollars on food I didn't
want over this $40 Sharky's given not
only that they made me wait for 20
minutes the food is getting cold they're
like not giving me the food like can you
imagine that like sir we can't give you
the food and then they make me pay and
then here's the best part I've had
brutal vicious diarrhea synthetic yeah
and like yesterday in the office I was
like Ian I'm so pissed at you but I
don't want to tell you why it's because
I was about to [ __ ] my pants from
Sharkies I make food great [ __ ] sharky's
[Laughter]
and although your gesture was thoughtful
in mmm-hmm I'm so over this card I'm
giving it back to you I do have to say
when I went to ask for the card they
seemed startled I said you have gift
cards in Charlotte shop Thanks
she's like are you insane you sure
Ian you should have taken that as a sign
this girl like no one has ever I said
I'm sorry
this card has given me nothing but grief
and now as I sit here before you on the
verge of [ __ ] my pants on this
Friday afternoon
$150 pour I want you to take this and I
want you to try to spend this money I
dare you to go to Sharky's and try to
spend this money and I and I and I
promise you in what bow falls you from
this point on is misery a curse upon you
diarrhea and you're gonna waste a
thousand dollars or you get a [ __ ] $1
for this part well you know I appreciate
the thought but my god
[Laughter]
well I appreciate the apology in but
some things just can't be taken back I
can't accept the curse no you go Ian you
don't have the option come here
can I take this time I'm serious dude
you taking this car from her it's
even if you could go back in time would
you have not given him the Prius what do
you think take the goddamn car alright
go spend that when you spend that let me
know we're gonna I want I guarantee that
when you do I spend that there's gonna
be and I want to follow up with you
before next week alright but thank you
and I swear to god I've been cursing his
name like when that happened the other
day and they're just like yeah I can't
believe you're turning your back on
Sharky's though no I'm done with turkeys
I'm dying perfection for Sharkies like
I'm not gonna lie but it's a person I
don't want it I return the curse to you
you can force it on someone else voiced
it I don't care give it it just Pat walk
by someone on the be like whatever you
do don't you know like give a warning
there's $40 on this don't try to spend
it that always thought about as a kid
cuz I'm so walking just like I'm crazy
like that if you go up to a random
stranger on the street and just be like
don't go to work today and then just
walk off I feel like a lot of people
have thought that just yeah yeah just
you know just get in someone's head a
total stranger yeah ever you do don't
would you take it seriously if someone
said that to you
probably no but it would freak me out it
would like it would [ __ ] my day up
probably whatever you do don't go to
home don't go home tonight that would
[ __ ] you up
cuz yet do they know where I live yeah
what are you doing at my yeah that would
[ __ ] my dad now everyone's gonna tell
that to me what now if somebody says
don't know don't go home tonight Dan you
got Kyle to Grandma [ __ ] email Kyle
the cougar champ sent down a really
great email I wanted him to read as a
follow-up to the interview we had with
them yeah yeah yeah he was very gracious
you know very appreciative
here it is let's see he said you know
honestly man I've done a lot of TV radio
podcasts and magazines where after I saw
the finished product I felt very
exploited and used with a ch3 I really
enjoyed the angle that you took on the
whole video on the podcast sweet [ __ ]
guy your crew was definitely one of my
better experiences so up to this point
you know really nice really gracious
here's where it takes a turn though full
disclosure I'm high as [ __ ] right now on
Molly with my 74 a 74 year old
girlfriend that I mentioned while I was
on the podcast as someone I really care
about we're on the beach florida and
have been together on and off for about
six months but Molly or not I love her
to death
hell I even babysat her one night after
a hospital visit you mean like you
stayed with your girlfriend why do you
think baby
no babysit means the old person who can
wipe their own ass oh I don't know does
it go on Dan you know he he babysat her
after a hospital visit that he was
partially responsible for no he didn't
break her [ __ ] Inc I was wondering what
happened was on our second date she was
really drunk and stood up too quickly
and fell through a glass table oh wow i
bandaged her up and took care of her
okay I'm rambling thanks again for
everything when he revealed that he was
on Molly throws everything into question
you guys are my favorite show I'm in
love with this grandma that I babysit
and smashed through glass tables what I
imagine he's just body slammed her on a
[ __ ] glass table it's pretty much
what he does like metaphorically with
their badges
all right email is going their own Molly
I don't know he's feeling good Kyle the
great the cougar champ it was in a
euphoric state it smelt like you know
sharing the love I think it's the
compliment no it's nice I thought it was
nice and it was funny it had a twister
that turns I love all that I'm really I
hope to hear more from Kyle my culture
my hope is that I want to get Kyle and
Skippy the virgin on the phone there you
go
what I would like is for Kyle the cougar
champ
to try to pitch to Skippy the Virgin
that he needs to start [ __ ] old
ladies
because Skippy's had a drive spell his
whole life and shredder is the cutest
god he's so cute oh my god and I think
that you know he was gonna miss shredder
when she's gone she's gonna be mean the
guy I think that that you know Skippy
could have a future slammin Cougars
through glass tables so we've got what
we got a couple more things here we've
got the Amazon you want to talk about
Amazon you want to talk about tattoo of
us well um I'm wondering if it's time
for the break because yeah we're and we
are diner stuff coming up do you want to
skip this stuff or talk about this stuff
we could skip skip and we can talk about
next time the nephew of us is so good
this clip is on [ __ ] real okay it
might be a video mm-hmm now everyone
wants to see it let me give you guys a
sneak peak of this [ __ ] it's so crazy
but it is break time all right let's
take a break it's just one so don't go
anywhere it's just a couple minutes I
swear to God I always say it's quick but
it's not this time it's quick we're
gonna watch this insane tattoo of us
when we get back god bless you
appreciate you roll it let's go
thank you to blue apron for sponsoring
us this episode blue apron is the
perfect fit for your goals to cook
healthy meals in the comfort of your
home they deliver farm-fresh ingredients
to your door and the exact proportions
you need for each meal here's what I
hate about trying to cook a meal myself
you go to the grocery store I need two
Leafs of cilantro so you have to buy a
bunch and you're like two leaves and
then what do I do with the rest of this
you can throw it out you have to throw
it out what am i cilantro
am I gonna eat it it's ridiculous this
means you don't have to dread those
grocery stores trips when you forget to
make the list before going I then stand
there awkwardly with your cart grating a
list while just really trying to find
what's one recipe you found no more of
that BS I don't like the grocery store
it's such a time sink
you know blue apron is here to save your
sanity and the day you simply choose
between two-person plan or the family
plan and you have eight different
recipes to choose from each and every
dangle flippin week pick and choose any
combo and let them gather everything you
need in order to create a delicious chef
inspired meal chef inspired I'm inspired
with new dishes added every week you can
try exciting and unique meals every
freaking dang goddamn flippin time and
if you don't like to slave away in the
kitchen for hours on end because all
blue apron meals can be prepared in 40
minutes or less here's how it works
but wait burned delivers the ingredients
in a refrigerator box so it stays fresh
even if you're not at home when your
package arrives that's actually true
we've left them outside our house for
like 10 hours a hot day till it's pretty
impressive man
plus you can recycle the packaging
either by returning it to blue apron
free via USPS or check out the recycling
locator on bloopers that's pretty cool I
didn't know that
because there is a lot of there's a lot
of packaging which is what makes it so
convenient but you end up with all this
plastic that's very cool I appreciate
that
the best part is there's no commitment
you can skip or cancel the service at
any time and prices start as low as
$8.99 per serving where are you gonna
get that for a gourmet meal where I'm
waiting it doesn't exist also you can't
answer me it's not two-way communication
but nobody dare to answer as for our
viewers go to blue apron dot-com
/ H 3 H 3 and get $50 off your first 2
boxes
what have they lost out there man that's
a lot of guac and and I'm we're talking
you know metaphorically and literally
that's a lot of guac it's a lot of
cheddar but they're just gonna deliver a
huge bag of guac and cheddar that's a
lot of get up here's your meal just take
the guac and cheddar put it in a bowl
eat it you fat [ __ ] I know that's what
you want if you are in the market to
avoid the market oh and have fresh
ingredients shipped to your doorstep
with delicious recipes weekly head on
over to blue apron com / h3h3 to check
out blue apron support the show and get
$50 off your first two boxes have they
lost their minds
say again that's blue apron calm / a
stray street thank you so much to put
the support us guys love you let's go
back and do the joke
okay what up we both ran through the
restroom and then Ethan didn't make it
back which is just more blame on Ian
because I don't know what's going on
with Ethan right now since Sharky's so
I'm very worried for Ethan so damn short
too short I was saying that I'm worried
about you because of Sharky's I didn't
know how long that was gonna be well now
I got it all out last night or yesterday
ones like this is the ones I had where
it's like it starts solid but I think a
cork pops off and then the dam is just
fully broken it's like oh you had you
are a healthy you know it's funny it
even happens to shredder one little cork
and then in that dam is Luke the juice
is loose as they say all right let me
give you a sneak peek at this clip but
we've got a great little segment plan
for for after this where is it
I want it there's I just I'm gonna tease
you because I'm sure you're all very
curious it's [ __ ] amazing probably
the one of the best videos ever the
premise of the show tat just tattoo of
us we're two supposed friends I say
suppose it because who the [ __ ] would do
this to their friend mmm give themselves
a tattoo while they're blind there could
be something nice
it could be something silly or give me
something like you're about to see now
okay so where's John John please
that guy who looks hella nervous that's
the guy who shows the tattoo oh there's
regret all right for Christ's sake get
on with it isn't gonna be happy with his
either you can no imagine that what oh
my god you know if I was trying the
thing like what could it be I would have
never thought I guess yes yeah
if you feel someone tattooing around
your belly button you can pretty much
sure it's gonna be a butthole yeah oh my
god there's a whole thing there that I
want to talk about let's move the show
along we can we can hit this next week
but uh friends man friends friendships a
crazy thing we've got a new segment
after the break voicemails yeah we set
up a voicemail box for people to leave a
message for us and we'll leave it on the
air
if you're drunk if you're happy if
you're chilling you got a question a
comment whatever you got for us leave it
here in the box
dan what's the number do you know what's
the number
yeah it's pulled up it's 8 1 8 2 1 4 8
504 we just threw it up on the screen
too so give us some ring guys here let's
let's see what we got here today I shall
try are we supposed to play the intro I
imagine like a Blue's Clues thing we got
mail today kids this is our editor by
the way he just got 5 teeth pulled
we told him to call in when he was all
[ __ ] up on laughing gasps well Alex
thanks for calling in I check it in I'm
glad you're doing okay he has recovered
and uh god bless him here we got a call
a message from Jimmy Lee really the
notorious outlaw dentist the dentist
yes the only time we've ever cut a guest
short on our show I've never told this
story before but I might as well now
Jimmy Lee has a special he's a special
spot in our Hall of Fame where we were
trying out a new thing bringing him all
cuz he's a more meme than man well yeah
yeah well let's try Jimmy lien see what
kind of you know beautiful train wreck
that is well is more train wreck than
beauty and during the first break me
heal and Dan we're in the corner and
we're like look this cannot go on we got
to cut this we got it we got to give him
the cane so we came back without him
obviously it's our fault for not
planning about her yeah and not knowing
what we're doing I mean he's a
hall-of-famer Jimmy leaves the Hall of
Famer let's see what he has to say about
it
hey Dan it's Jimmy Lee give me a call
when you can
I want to do invitees and inhalants at
Las Vegas I'm doing a comedy shoot next
week and I'm just gonna invite them out
to have fun and enjoy
but then he emailed me to give you a
quote maybe I call into the show so when
you get a time when you get a chance
call me and you know we can figure out
maybe I'm working with Mike did you call
him dance he called me I missed the call
did you miss her yeah yeah I missed her
we got to get Jimmy on the air I want to
hear some of his new material I mean you
you have an invitation to go hear it in
person in Vegas I should do I don't hate
the guy but I wouldn't mind giving him
that Sharky's gift card and just seeing
if he can make that way on the air but
uh I've seen Howard Stern's penis and uh
pretty [ __ ] big well I'm not sure how
he would have ever gotten in that
position to see Howard Howard always
jokes that is a small dick yeah yeah he
runs he maintains that his penis is very
small which is something that I've
always appreciated about how honest he
is and if he's actually rocking a big
one then I feel like that undermines
everything that we know celebrity right
it's gone
I don't be I don't buy it I don't buy it
I think it goes a little tiny little
baby toe I don't think he's got it
I don't know that was a thing well I
like Howard would you assume well yeah
he's really tall right do you think he
had a big one proportionate to the body
you thought about how are dick huh well
not until you brought it up that no it's
not if you're a tall guy with a little
one it's even worse it looks smaller
yeah just like damn good yeah it looks
smaller and especially if you have long
pubes it just gets lost in there man
well we need proof yeah Howard Howard
Stern if you're listening know the guy
Howard Stern if you're listening please
send us pictures of your giant dick
no but for real guys out there if you're
trying to make your look bigger look
bigger right dick look bigger trim the
pubes really short because if you got
[ __ ] crazy pubes and a little one and
you're tall like your dick will get lost
in that pubic forest or rain forest it's
like you know you got it you got to help
yourself not speaking from experience
just saying you can't make it look a
little bigger I want to hear more from
that guy yeah why you so mad man I want
to hear more from him Dan follow up with
that guy want to hear more I want to
hear more about what you know at some
ascetics of his age well yes I'm okay
nicely hating us that much but also
having the presence of mind to call him
leave a message I find that he must
follow the Twitter to down the number no
even it's your boy Zach I just got
married you know like about a month ago
and it's all good it's on this video
game donkey sounds like Jason done it
nice you know and whatever but like I
just gotta ask you for some advice man
like she never lets me have my beans out
like this does Eli but let you have your
bangs out when she works I'm an hour
later than I do right so I come home
hour before and you know I'm just trying
to play I'm trying to get some dubs with
my boys on fortnight and I'm having my
beans out and then she comes home to our
apartment and throws a fit and tells me
to put pants on she knows I play better
when I do I hang out with my a naked I
assume he means maybe not even naked
maybe his balls are just out the whole
other side let him breathe not at the
side wears out the side oh I see just
don't ya know at the hold and not at the
side you dig it extra support when
they're at the hole they breathe like on
a little cot yeah I rock my bean
regula no you don't be honest when you
see me naked cuz I walk around naked not
a lot but like in between bed and
outfits
is that a [ __ ] brutal site be honest
because you see but make it a lot and
I'm very conscious of that but it's like
at a certain point you just gotta live
your life is that a brutal sight seeing
me butt naked I don't have just tell me
I'm not sensitive is it brutal no really
you're sparing my feelings but I would
not want to see your beans out and we
were playing video cancer that guy all
right but like when I'm but nass naked
not a sock not a hat how brutal is that
when you wet when you're in the shower
breath it's the morning you're brushing
your teeth you turn around there's my
butt ass naked body what do you think
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah cuz that's what I
think when I see my I'm like damn this
must be shocking you know what I mean
alright god bless ya
howdy boys playing fortnight I don't
know why I'm here
I'm gonna hang up now enjoy fortnight oh
boy nice that's yeah that's right there
I hope you got the win on that one boy
delivering pizzas healing while you're
working for Pizza Hut sadly not Papa
John's as they would not hire me no dude
Papa John has been snubbing this show
for so frickin long like I've been
trying to get a sponsorship from Papa
John we started the Papa John culture
he's on the news now bro world the news
people talk about Papa John culture oh
h3z controversial site kicked off the NS
NFL hmm we're more made to mash you hate
black people
I will Papa John apparently hates well
no yeah but where are you going about
that we're both controversy he hates
black people and I think that it's okay
to wear a Chinese dress same thing not
according to her the lady on Fox News
according to her okay her ash did
I'm sick of Papa John's [ __ ] I
[ __ ] so sick of Papa John I'd it's
even papa
didn't he didn't he have his papa hood
he's just gonna well this is John John
yeah you're just John oh I'm John who
cares
Papa's not in the house get real music
from the game find interesting I teach
at a middle school here in Miami and I
just witnessed a fight because one kid
called another kid crash at fortnight
and the kid
proceeded to break his nose it went
extremely close hands and I would like
your blessing and and maybe it's oh yeah
he's a teacher who saw a fight break up
because someone said their trash had for
tonight Oh trash times are changing my
dude I had one fight over Tekken when I
was a kid no I didn't instigate it but I
was cheesing this one kid he was a piece
of [ __ ] by the way but we brought him
over his house nobody liked him real
[ __ ] I choose him out on Tekken I
kept doing the same move over and over
but it was so high level that he
couldn't counter it so he got so
frustrated put me in a headlock and my
dog at the time came and bit his ass get
out never come back times maybe aren't
that different as they were um let's see
what else we got here I got a couple
more here let's you know he's in the
Neela you guys are great but I just
wanted to ask Ethan something why do you
like Elon Musk's so much I mean he's
such a jackass and a terrible person but
maybe I'm over-exaggerating
I just don't like him that much can you
explain yourself well if you're a fan of
the show you would haven't I've
explained myself I've written a thesis
dissertation it's
it's part of everything that I am now
where's your supporting evidence you say
he's a jack why why what is your
reasoning except that you're just a
contrarian who likes stuff who likes to
hate stuff because it's popular Oh
Ilan so cool oh he's a perfect human oh
he sent a roadster to [ __ ] Mars and
it was playing David Bowie and space wow
what a jackass sorry what do you do I'm
sorry you probably worked for John's not
even Papa didn't he say that he's
starting eye candy come yeah hello oh
he's just trying to make some money
you're trying to raise some bills hmm
that's a weird one though I got it man
the candy thing was my name at candy
candy doesn't seem like the most
profitable sure is it weirder than
flamethrowers no the Flip there was
dubbed the flamethrower was very cool
what's a problem candy because candy is
very I just associated with like if you
look at Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory there's the candy man yeah candy
man he's like a weird guy Candy Man can
he's heading into a Willy Wonka figure
your walk around the lollipops talking
about your selling candy I'm getting
concerned is that the same time he's
talking about building tunnels under the
ground all the Sunny's and those tummies
with lollipops who's coming into that
tunnel kids say the Candy Man can
what can the Candy Man do [ __ ] kids so
it's a little strange I don't know you
never know I'm just it's a weird match I
agree I was like why you and like and
you know how that song ends the Candy
Man from Charlie chocolate me play this
the Candy Man
Charlie like the way he ends is so
ominous like I'm definitely gonna [ __ ]
your kid like listen this other way I
love this movie it's very dark though
much darker than people think and here's
a case he goes on and on and on My dear
boy dee you can take a rainbow you can
take a kid's dick
put it in his hand and take them
underground okay but now listen to me
finish the song
the Candy Man can cause he mixes it with
love and makes the world taste is
conquered and the world tastes good
cause the Candy Man things no no no no
there's like home nope nope nope
Charlie's like he doesn't know any
better you know I mean he wants to get
in there with that Candy Man but he
can't hear that oh it's like a minor
note so it's off I love this movie I
love it it's a great one I just closed
my whole [ __ ] browser okay guys hang
on like he's working on the boring
company if you live in LA
that's anyone who's gonna solve the
traffic issue here he's an angel and
that makes it Elon an ancient angel
thank you all right I got the document
also my mom's name is Alana I'm his name
is Elon well how the [ __ ] about Dutchess
so he's got to be an angel the proof is
in the pudding guys it's right there in
the pudding have a bite take a sniff all
right next up we got another segment I
wanted to look at I was I was blown away
a little bit by this Twitter exchange by
Logan Paul and this comedian Chris
D'Elia
this guy Chris D'Elia he's funny he's a
good comedian
yeah affectional comedian I actually
didn't know him before I saw the tweets
but you can tell he's one guy a comedian
if ever you want it like Logan is
attempting to heckle him in a way and
it's like you don't go to a stand-up
show as a pleb or anyone really but if
you heckle a professional comedian
that's what they're good at
yeah you know what I mean you're gonna
get handled and boy Logan tried so hard
to adjust with this professional
comedian and he looked dumber and dumber
every tweet and even me I was like just
stop bro just stop this is so and
Bera Singh oh my god so by the way Ian's
back there I'm curious can you look on a
social blade or some stats website I'm
curious how many followers did Chris
D'Elia gain during this exchange because
Logan thought he was slam dunking on him
but now everyone's talking about this
like this is one of his tweets had like
half a million likes and Logan's Paul's
was like 10,000 which is like you have
hordes of kids and that's all you can
muster all right let's get into this
here god bless america
it works solo it starts with Logan new
vlog the end of Logan Paul vlogs
important that you watch and then he
comes out you just know it's not okay
not fun yeah not that it's not that big
of a deal no joke you're gonna come at
everybody who takes a little goof on you
also he's making funnier clickbait like
it's not it's important that you wash no
it's not that's true okay
look at all this crying laughing emojis
dog you're already off yeah you already
lost
you already lost I'm laughing cuz I know
why your comedy career took a dive that
many crying laughing faces you're so
insecure it's just so not even fitting
here like imagine that his response was
just like like bro you're so insecure
with that many [ __ ] faces alright
when and what did what what exactly his
response have to do with his comedy
career taking it yeah like it's not
related it's just it's like a child
trying to make an insult well at least
when my career dies you can film it and
put it on YouTube so like Logan Paul
eventually he set up the Olly
Kobe Bryant during the all-star dunk
slam ten out of ten
he just said they're like son
six hundred sixty-three thousand likes
and you know the best part you know it's
the best part when you look at the
quoted tweet it's just crying laughing
emojis so okay now he probably should
have left it at that
he already he should have never
responded definitely but he's like I'm a
Logan Paul I have a seven million dollar
house and C know that the property tax
alone is gonna make me bankrupt in three
years by the way that's true he owns a
seven million seven news seven and a
half million dollar house in Encino the
property tax on that alone it's like 1.2
percent a year or something right well
the math on that Mike I mean seventy
thousand is that what it is a year for
property tax that's like I'm super high
salary even got the stats here on the
where you guys um do I have it I don't
know
26,000 follows on the day but the day
the day before it 200 hmm that's like a
10,000 comedy clear is dead I'm not
insecure I'm not totally insecure that I
have to respond to every person that
give something on Twitter so here we go
and now Logan's like bro I'm a I'm the
funniest most charismatic dude in the
world I'm gonna clap back right now by
not gonna live this single tweet is
funnier than your entire Netflix special
so he's like I'm gonna give you credit
this suite was dope
but you're not dope buddy still gotta be
mean yeah and then of course the next
thanks how does it feel to have your
name finally tested something funny
250,000
just let it go at this point I'm
watching this on Mike Logan let it go
this is gonna get worse for you the
pattern you're not gonna be able to spam
crying laughing oh geez you're way out
of this oh [ __ ] we have actually a
callin from you know this kid Jordan
who's like I'm sure we'll have some
interesting insights hmm
how does he respond I don't know what's
worse being the shunned vlogger so
pathetic it's like we cheer up dude all
right
we have disgraced vlogger or being the
38 year old community hello hey Jordan
while you were picking on Logan for
what's what's the deal we are talking
about his conversation with Chris D'Elia
on Twitter I saw I was looking on reddit
there I think that's up but all deep
things it's all deep fake really it says
did you go on twitter.com slash Logan
Paul and see his tweets there how do you
deep fake a Twitter comment what I heard
it was lip tarts doing that and I don't
know why you're always picking on him
you're always making him seem like he's
some big bad evil d-von but he's just a
nice guy like you and me he goes and
pays his taxes he kisses a teen over
girls on the other cheek and everything
he's a good man did tell me let me ask
you this what do you think about crying
laughing emojis do you think that's a
good response do you support this I'm
laughing because I know you're your
comedy career tada well okay well here
let me continue you just calm down
this is family I'm gonna keep reading
these tweets okay if you have something
to add let me know but first of all it's
not a decent
I'll tell you what I would have said so
here he said I don't know it's worth
being the shun vlogger or being the 38
year old comedian arguing with the shun
vlogger on Twitter I like he's
insinuating that 38 years old is like 38
year old like your old dude old I guess
they're I guess that's a good point 38
is yeah that's pretty much the end of
your life I saw that if you're not a
vlogger by 18 you should [ __ ] jump
off a bridge I don't know I heard some
old are you Jordan how much fears you
got left
well I got a sickness really yeah it's
not a joke it's not a bit
okay well I'll attach to a breathing
machine right now I don't know why
you're always bringing this stuff up to
put me down so how old are you why
should that get in the way of your
vlogging career 13 I can't play soccer
anymore yeah five years Jordan I don't
know why you think it's funny that I'm
sick and I got Elvis pills I gotta take
all right I don't know it's worse being
the tion blogger or being the 38 year
old comedian arguing with the shunned
blogger over Twitter what's so sad it's
this Saturday it's the most sad pathetic
attempt I had to come back I've ever
heard of my life also whenever you bring
up age yeah like oh I'm young so
therefore I win this argument yeah yeah
you're also you know why is that wrong
you're jealous cuz you know got
fifteen-year-old pubes anymore dude yeah
you got old pubes though what is the
what is a 15 year old pube look like are
they different some I call the FBI this
guy why do you say that for all right
thank you
well I could before you go I know we
have a lot of rivalry we have a lot of
evil that's between us but I want to say
I know yeah I know you got a lot of
money you got a lot of me in the bank
and I was wondering if you would invest
if I start up the fake program and I'm
not trying I'm not trying to commit a
c-class felony under Title 18
but I know listen I do have a lot of
illegal technologies I'd like you to
invest that we can you know you go ahead
and email us about that and we'll take
it from there
Jordan well that really derailed things
on I thought he was gonna have something
more insightful to say about yeah I'm
sorry every time when I screen him yeah
he seems like he's calm he's coherent
and then he just loses it Jordan you're
blowing it dude I didn't know Jordan was
sick
doesn't sound sick but why does he 38 is
not that old bro serious I just can't
get over this he's not arguing with you
by the way he slam dunk you're arguing
you were the one arguing with him
he is [ __ ] a looping Kobe Bryant
Shaquille O'Neal in that tight twink
little ass VIIRS why is it going to
himself as Shonda flogger I don't know
what I don't know the wardens disgraced
he's like trying to like
self-deprecating I mean like yeah I'm
shunned but look at you hmm who are you
38 year old you [ __ ] you're basically
dead oh nice of you to take some time
out of your convalescent home to come
[ __ ] with me on Twitter at 38 years old
don't you have a funeral to be planning
aren't you retired or something god I
love this Logan Paul looks like him
what's he's doing at age 38 you know I
mean there's your night to see plastic
surgery yeah probably ask your fans to
have their moms read this tweet out loud
to them see what they think
yeah that's true
his fans are definitely 12 years old I
mean who else would get get hard-on for
a 30 making fun of a 38 year old 38
that's a young man am I wrong
no you're not wrong 38 that's one year
like
that's when you're slamming those those
are the golden years so that's like when
you made it yeah
you got some money you're [ __ ] you're
starting to [ __ ] it it's a good point in
your life starting to trim your pubes
trying to understand a trim your pubes
so your dick looks bigger you know
[Music]
you've got some hems viagra just in case
it's not a very angry this is you are
getting a little bit old and you know
not like when you were 18 it's certainly
not when you were like 13 dude when I
went you know it's crazy I think my
libido was at the highest my sex drive
was at its highest when I was like 13
do you know what I mean like my dick was
hard pretty much 23 hours of the day I
put my dick in a tree fire is that
normal for most guys I probably I don't
know that's pretty typical because I
think back man it's crazy it's just it's
crazy it's weird how nature [ __ ] with
you because yeah it's both the [ __ ] when
you're 13 but somehow that's it's listed
you really definitely too young when
that from when did you hit your max
libido ela I don't know probably older
than 13 really yeah huh
for sure older than 13 all right I won't
push it but uh but the a major yeah
teenage like 18 mm-hmm
I think I don't I mean wasn't paying
attention so then it wasn't that bad for
you I guess I was like this I was
afflicted by a disease I had boner
I had boner boner syndrome I just
boner brightest thank you every guy has
been in this situation when you're on
the school bus and you got you popped
such a fat one just simply from the
vibrations of the bus and you've got to
tuck it under the belt somehow which is
a tough maneuver because you got a you
know I do that front-facing sling of the
backpack
a trick right there isn't every deal
with this back then in front it's just
probably just shuffle on three like you
know you gotta get something in there
but it's I would pray to God that my
dick would deflate before the bus
stopped I was like cut please not today
just please God let it go down that's
funny guys have a different reality yeah
no it's it's nuts man by the time I turn
18 I was like yeah I had like evened out
quite a bit you know but it's crazy
anyway I think we digressed a little bit
old people roasting me greatest thing on
planet Earth can you believe 20,000 kids
like this that is the dumbest but all
the paperboys thing may have hurt bro
he's 26 you're 20 you were gonna be 30
soon you just like know that study got
roasted know old people roasting me yeah
it is the greatest thing on earth
because your fans they're not even
capable of having okay a coherent
thought how are you gonna call and
thirty-eight year old guy old people
like it just shows how he started his
world his fan base is like 12 13 14 yeah
these people are only your fan Logan
because they're not capable of
understanding what a shitty dude you are
cuz you're just like the cool the cool
kid from school you know when you look
back when you turned 30 and you look
back at the cool kid in school you
realize what a [ __ ] douchebag that's
you right now and I feel like by the age
of 27
he's already not in high school that's
what I mean he shouldn't know that about
himself
old people roasting me why would you
even tweet that how about this you're my
son tag your [ __ ] daddy I'm your
daddy that's crazy man Chris this whole
exchange is really similar to your life
as time passes your jokes get less and
less funny sorry daddy you know he was
sitting around with like his whole posse
yeah
[Music]
so we team ten they all wrote this
together yeah the whole team ten crew
wasn't on that
you know what will be even less funny
when your fans grow up and become mine I
mean that's right that's a girl that's
not even a joke that's just a statement
of fact you know what I'm saying it's
like Logan get out now I wasn't
following this fart out you know what
will be even less funny when you don't
when you continue when they don't yeah
when they don't and you continue to make
podcasts in your basement for the rest
of your life
Logan I'm afraid to say that that seems
more prophetic for you than it does you
know what I mean he's so defensive like
it almost just shows like - yes get out
hmm he's trying and the thing is he's
not being funny he's just trying to be
like a mean yeah he's like I know I got
you I just I just tapped into your
deepest fears and you'll never forget
about this insightful comment that you
shattered the whole reality I know that
your deepest darkest fears that you
nobody will like doing to make podcasts
in your basements forever and I just
tapped into that you're old - did I
mention that clap back something popped
back the emoji and Chris is like this is
the best thing ever I'm never stopping
why should he ever stop so far you've
called me daddy admitted to watching my
entire comedy special are you trying to
burn me or [ __ ] me going it's Piett by
the way low gang [ __ ] is what happens
when two people love each other very
much so I think at this point we've
exhausted the UH the think tank - like
yo we need a break man we've been
thinking all day this is when Nick
Crompton left then on that last twit by
the way Eli I know you've been talking
about team ten I don't want to bearish
you a correct you on the air but team
ten is separate from the Logan whoo all
right Wow I don't want embarrassed
respect you as my wife but I have to say
I really [ __ ] up my research here
embarrassing are we ready for the last
break I mean let's see I think so it's
4:40 I mean yeah I guess we could we
have a bunch of news but we've already
been going through 40 yeah you want us
to just save the news or what do you
want to do but it's relevant now let's
just do a couple of headlines then so
let's have Ellis Ella's our news lady
send the nudes we should do it before
commercial why because we have a
crossover to do during the commercial
let's just do the show then let's do the
band all right
I don't new because I wanted to do the
nudes you want to just read a couple
headlines
let me read my favorite one actually you
know what it's kind of should I save it
for next no I'm gonna do the break and
then we'll uh we'll come back and do
this okay mm-hmm all right we'll be
right back eva is gonna new the news and
we have a live performance from chaos
chaos you do not want to leave i frickin
guarantee it we'll be right back thank
you to expressvpn for sponsoring us
Facebook has been in the news a lot
lately getting thrashed for letting
third parties get your user data but do
you really think they're the only ones
doing it I don't I know they're not the
Internet's become the wild wild west
it's time to stop trusting big
corporations with their data and start
protecting it with express VPN with
expressvpn you can privately and
securely surf the internet without being
tracked by anyone and trust me if you
look at the stuff that I do online you
do not want anyone to know like a burger
recipe burger recipes don't you track my
recipes if if the FBI sent Eva all the
burger recipes I've been looking on the
internet I've used so much trouble I
don't want anyone to know what I'm
looking on the Internet
hang it up on all devices only took me a
few minutes it's seriously the easiest
fricking app to run and it seamlessly
rocks on rock and roll's in the
background of my desktop laptop
smartphone and/or
tablet and protects me while I'm
browsing streaming downloading emailing
and rock-and-rolling
and looking up the most craziest burger
recipes you can possibly imagine would
make you blush if you knew but you but
nobody does because I use expressvpn
nice for less than seven bucks a month
you can get the same expressvpn that
protects me and you can look up all the
weird effed up crap
like why I don't know I'm just I don't
know
hentai I don't know that's all I can
think about that's it that's all I got
every expressvpn plan is covered by risk
free 30-day money-back guarantee I'm
joking but it's really about it's
serious you don't I don't want Facebook
selling my data and having like foreign
agents serving me propaganda it's to
stop [ __ ] like that yeah sup YouTube and
Facebook and Instagram and the goddamn
government yeah spying on me I want a
little privacy on the Internet
oh god that's the only place we've got
it left not anymore
but with expressvpn the the VP stands
for very private now VPN expressvpn
experience the freedom privacy and
safety that expressed me being Gibbs
you're never gonna want to use the
internet again without it ain't that the
truth
to take back your internet privacy today
find out how you can get three months
free Wow
go to expressvpn comm /h 3 that's expr
ESS VPN comm / h 3 4 3 months free what
the 1-year package don't put this off
guys protect your internet and data with
expressvpn today that's expressvpn duck
up such h3 nice changing the game don't
forget very private very private
now press VPN guys thank you so much
let's get right the flippin heck back
right into it and thank you to our
sponsors thank you
you
what the sound ended abruptly oh sorry
to [ __ ] you up already [ __ ] we switched
seats you'll see on the news we had to
switch cosy turns laptop was plugged
into the stuff so what are the headlines
today so the first one that I already
started to talk about is that Nick
Crompton has left him dead don't - come
on don't say that this is very huge news
don't basically he left him 10 do we
know why he said the reason for his
departure is due to internal changes
being made with various businesses and I
don't agree with it anymore
wow that's kind of other words drama
drama
damn it was like I don't people when I
do people left Tim tan it was abrupt and
I wanted to do it properly and I'm gonna
leave a statement but then he doesn't
actually say why I'm gonna leave
properly and let me just say that I
don't agree with all their shade
[ __ ] yeah okay well rest of these
the Brompton don't don't look don't
instead I have resigned both as chief
operations officer and as a talent by
the way the fact that that guy was the
CEO just cracks me up yeah oh yeah this
is a legit organization I'm just some
random 18 year old I'm chief executive
officer or just chief CLO okay the the
biggest news story that I wanted to tell
you is mm-hmm
is that the UK is banning wet wipes I
don't like that I don't know how are you
gonna leave once that happens here but
well I don't think I don't see that
happening this is America this is the
home of freedom and bravery they said
many wet wipes are mistakenly flushed
down the toilet after use see that's the
problem we use flushable wipes but I
think even we use too many probably they
they say only one for flush that's like
how they say just take one Advil and
everyone's like I think they really mean
it they're just like covering their ass
you know and metaphorically speaking N
and literally either way everybody takes
like five to seven advil at once right
no anyway since they do not break down
clump and cone congeal with cooking
grease and other discarded items and as
a result clogged the words sewer systems
the world's the war holy [ __ ]
it's almost makes sense that baby wipes
they're too good to be we've told the
story about how we destroyed the
plumbing at our apartment in Israel yeah
I don't know if we talked about it here
but we when we were living in Israel we
had just discovered baby wipes and I
don't think we were using flushable ones
because we didn't know that that was a
thing we had like the big crazy baby
wipes like really heavy cloth and we
were just really enjoying having our
asses clean you know yeah and a couple
months you know after living there that
whole area started smelling like raw
sewage just like awful and we're like
this is disgusting what is wrong with
this building man this is [ __ ] up and
then a week later there's a sign on
everyone's door in the apartment
whoever's using baby wipes has destroyed
the building septic tank please stop
using baby wipes and that did you like
major construction outside on the pipes
and stuff did we stop using baby wipes
we did back in there we had no choice I
think that's when we got flushable the
next story which I also really found
interesting because we recently moved so
I had to do that change of address where
you give the post office your new
address and then they forward all your
address all your mail to the new address
and they give you this form and all they
ask is just fill in your name your
previous address your new address and
that's it no verification I think no I
sure no idea when I did it I called
Ethan and I was like this is so easy
like anyone could do that to anyone else
what how is that the process so now this
man allegedly used change of address
form to move the UPS headquarters to his
apartment that's the best role ever and
basically you got a bunch of their mail
didn't it's a HELOC cash my checks fifty
eight thousand dollars in check that's
pretty stupid
however sleep cashing checks aren't
addressed to him you expect there's all
these fail safes in this
system but there's nothing this dude
just changed his address to UPS
headquarters started caching random
people's checks it says they went on for
months how the hell they not realize
that they're not getting mail for two
months and now he faces federal charges
for mail theft they'll let him out once
he changes his fort arrest to the White
House it apparently carries a maximum
sentence of five years
oh and mail fraud which could be up to
20 don't [ __ ] with the mill yeah let
that be known to everyone out there
thinking of affording our address I will
punish with the maximum a sentence
allowable um Spotify is gonna stop
promoting artists of that are related to
hateful conduct for example or Kelly
yeah that guy yeah I wonder what do you
think about it cuz they're not gonna
it's cut they're not gonna remove him
from the platform they're just not gonna
promote him anymore it's pretty
interesting but it's always strange to
be the person that makes that value
judgment on someone yeah you know I mean
um I think as long as they say who it is
they're punishing cuz it's super [ __ ]
up when I mean this is something YouTube
does is they'll [ __ ] with channels and
they won't say which channels they're
[ __ ] with yeah that is not healthy
for any community it's weird
I don't know it's weird I mean I guess I
get it why would they want to promote
someone who runs like a sex cult like
our Kelly it's a weird one it's a tough
call I mean their statement they said as
you can imagine this is a complicated
process with room for debate and
disagreement so we can't get into an
artist by artists discussion in general
we work with our partners and try to
make decisions on a case-by-case basis
it's real interesting what about Chris
Brown like I punched beat the [ __ ] out
of real that's the thing where do you
draw yeah although our Kelly is pretty
he's got a whole course on another level
he's not just yeah you know trips me out
John Lennon I know people always talk
about this but if he was living today he
like beat the [ __ ] at a woman
hmm you know I mean and back then it was
just like eight keep your baby keep your
girl in check and now what Chris Brown
can't punch Rihanna in the face but back
then like you said it wasn't as it's not
today I don't know if he would do it
today
I suppose blows my mind you could just
slap your wife that's crazy all right
mmm Albertsons is being sued for forcing
their employees to speak English only
huh what does that mean like amongst
themselves like hey no you have to speak
English amongst yourselves
so not only among but yeah amongst
themselves like on break and break the
they can't speak any other language
that's pretty [ __ ] that is all yeah
how do you enforce that 8english lead
the store developed an unwritten policy
that prohibited Hispanic employees from
spinning Spanish around non-spanish
speakers including when speaking to
Spanish speakers speaking customers and
during breaks sorry
can you imagine customers trying to
speak Spanish I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
not allowed to speak Spanish that's a
weird one guys that's a weird one
Albertson's it's like just one paranoid
like upper manager who was worried that
people were gossiping about him in
Spanish he's like that's it no more
[ __ ] Spanish in this household um
unicorn milk is in trouble in San
Francisco Dan what that's that its
flavored vape juice is gonna be banned
in San Francisco because I mean then
they got a point they got a point I'm
sure they do but I want to hear it well
what do you think that Dan basically
they think it's like inducing for young
kids you know like here's cereal and
milk well you know back in the day they
outlawed making cartoon characters for
cigarettes hmm they used to have and and
because they thought the same thing it's
pandering to children I don't know where
this idea came along
that tasty flavors are for children only
like as soon as you cross 18 it's like
nothing but brussel sprouts for you
buddy
it makes it more accessible right like
there's this one treat that blows my mom
when I was a kid they used to have
powdered cigarettes
there was little cigarettes rolled you
know puff it and sugar like powder sugar
will come out it's such an insane thing
to give your [ __ ] it does make it more
accessible they're like oh I want some
unicorn jizz you know in my mouth Oh
kids are all about but maybe you could
just you know tweak the title of it yeah
another clip I really enjoyed this week
is sorry I'm trying to get used to your
laptop mice is not dragging it do you
see that
I hate Windows they do this thing where
it snaps back it's like I don't know
distance yeah this is great
so this girl was hospitalized so she
couldn't come to her graduation but she
showed up on a tablet on a robot this is
amazing [ __ ] I ever seen in my life it's
a tablet on a Segway wearing a cap and
gown rolling down the podium accepting a
diploma with her like they dress the
robot I'm sure was like a beautiful
moment for her but my god is a goofy
[ __ ] and she stand there like Segway
standing next to Oliver there's a girl
like [ __ ] I'm next to the Segway yeah I
mean how am I supposed to focus on
anyone else that's it the last thing is
that Sin City eight it's barely some
sort of like a sex festival oh yeah is
attempted attempting the biggest orgy in
the world that las vegas and that is
absolutely disgusting like what is the
hook there they're going to a hotel
right yeah
so imagine embassy suits Embassy Suites
embassies you can never
go to that hotel again it's good what
are they gonna put up a sign we hosted
the biggest orgy the world has ever
known as I love is in every corner I
love that a Guinness rep had to make a
statement he said I can't come for him
this is not a record title that we
recognize or monitor
therefore there will not be a Guinness
World Record
just to do with the clipboard there were
they will not but yeah that would be a
tough gig to do they just he he just has
his balls out of his zipper so he
doesn't feel he doesn't feel like yeah
weird weird
I forgot the word but there's an FAQ on
the website and like apparently single
man can't come oh really because it
would just be like a thousand dudes
trying to get one check bring a date
that's how swingers roll hmm what about
STDs is on their FAQ I would say all
participants will receive complimentary
condoms complimentary
Wow you know those people aren't going
to be using condoms I don't even want to
be outside that I don't want to be in
the same state of that hotel because
that [ __ ] is aerosol takes new forms
when you have that many [ __ ] rygan
rubbing together those STDs all gonna go
airborne and all of Las Vegas is gonna
be infected by this new hepatitis Y
stands for why Oh watch out watch out
everybody so I can just read it mean you
could just go there you don't need to
know anyone do they ever pass judgment
I'm like what you look like they want
they want a lot of people right they're
going to good looks are optional I don't
think there was no barrier for entry no
damn you know everyone's gonna be like
an orgy sounds fun when you're like oh
everyone's so beautiful and not in fit
but in reality orgies are like me in 15
years yeah like a couple more beers a
couple more burritos you know big-ass
pubes
you wonder if my pubes ever got long
enough that could braid them to my
[ __ ] hairs why I'm great like a hair
diaper that's when I'll know I'm ready
for the orgy I don't think anyone has
ever wonder that I'm a great something
you think about a lot no I just thought
that right now just a great I'm a great
mind in think about great things and
that's true much like Prince ie I'm kind
of on a higher level of your weight your
walk is [ __ ] yeah well once we can can
join the forces of my pubes and [ __ ]
hairs then we'll know you look that is
something you're old and Louis posin old
during this podcast from the basement
know what I was gonna say is that you'll
take my hand and we'll go to an orgy I
don't know that I would take your hand
if you had this what if I was wearing a
condom thing you're talking on my mind I
hand condoms yeah that's a thing a hand
condom for like finger-banging like a
glove yeah you put a little I swear to
god it's in there put the condom on your
finger so that you can which is
rearranged to me it's like if you're
that what is earned not about putting a
finger in a girl's vagina don't do it I
don't think so unless you're like I mean
I guess you find a girl that disgusting
that you need to cover your finger just
don't don't put it in to begin with oh
we're gonna be at a point in humanity
where you need to saran wrap your whole
[ __ ] just like bum bum hips all right
well good job you on the news that was
great thank you so we are gonna hop on
over to the main stage and have a live
performance with chaos chaos let's let's
hop on over there it's gonna be a total
blast let's take it hang out for one sec
so this is life they can hear me
you got the cue card Dan yeah all right
so this is chaos chaos guys can you see
me
hello Cass Cass new self-titled album is
now on all streaming platforms featured
on Spotify under new releases you guys
are going on a national tour starting
next week you guys can get tickets at
chaos chaos band calm how you doing
we're good Mike I've got reverb too so
what song are you guys prepared to play
right now we're gonna do a new song
called blue chaos scare self out titled
cool well let's let's take it away guys
[Music]
Vincent
me
that you
Oh
in the
[Music]
something you don't wanna move
[Music]
you're refer only a kiss follow
your fields with beasts now can I
so please do too
cannot
you don't wanna do
[Music]
something weird happened oh I know I was
like someone you should have came over
here and use this mic she is using a
broken pedal that could be why should we
do it again or just do the next song
yeah did it sound that bad just me
singing or would we have time to do it
again I have this good luck charm here
usually it works guess it didn't work
maybe it has to be turned the other way
I'm wondering maybe it needs yeah I
think that's it okay it's working all
right
this might not work well we are the
guinea pigs right isn't this the first
first live show it's got more characters
this way I nobody wants a Polish show
nobody okay whatever
yeah was it ever working
alright let's give it another shot
alright we're actually gonna start at
midway through okay it's exciting it's
wild it's off the road we're kicking up
dust alright actually I think it was
shredder shredder came over no generous
no-one knows there's a dog no traitor
you sabotage
all right we got shredder okay take it
away guys this is blue
blue version two
only I can find love
you're filled with bees now
so close
you cannot
[Music]
you don't wanna do
[Music]
all right is this thing on okay good
that was blue by Cass Cass it worked
this time I'm it man we are really off
the road here guys all right that
sounded awesome you guys killing it you
guys want are gonna do one more song
what is it called the song is called
pink politics pink politics all right
guys god bless take it away
shredder keep yourself
[Music]
I piss my anger on the table
[Music]
now you
Oh baby
this is
[Music]
there's a memory
bananana
[Music]
that was amazing that sounded so good
pink politics wow thanks for having us
thank you so much that was incredible
you guys their self-titled album KS KS
is available everywhere where music is
streamed that [ __ ] and if you want to
see them live head on over to KS KS band
calm for tickets you guys are going on
tour in just a couple days right
Wednesday well guys if you want to hear
more go freaking get better ding do it
because these guys are amazing all right
thank you guys everyone for watching
thank you Cass Cass
thank you everybody we'll see you next
Friday god bless hope you have a great
weekend and appreciate you very much
guys we'll see you next time
Tata